quelques rayons de soleil sur le visage
malgré un port du masque fraîchement
imposées par les autorités polonaises
depuis ce samedi
jusqu'ici le port d'écran faciaux de
protection ou de foulard suffisait mais
en raison d'une résurgence de l'épidémie
depuis la mi février le ministre
polonais de la santé a annoncé de
nouvelles restrictions ce mercredi nous
nous orientons vers une limitation des
entrées à la frontière nous allons aussi
devoir régionaliser les restrictions une
régionalisation des restrictions
notamment pour la région barney mazurie
dans le nord-est du pays où la situation
est la plus alarmante avec des taux
d'infection qui représente plus du
double de la moyenne nationale dans
cette partie du pays
installations sportives lieux culturels
hôtels et nombre d'écoles resteront
fermées dans le reste du pays les bars
restaurants hôtels discothèques et club
de gym ainsi que la plupart des écoles
resteront fermées
à l'inversé des stations de ski des
cinémas des hôtels et des théâtres qui
ont rouvert depuis quelques semaines le
gouvernement affirme cependant que ces
libertés pourront être révoqués
si le nombre de cas augmente de nouveau
pour les polonais ces temps de
restriction sont comme beaucoup une
nouvelle réalité à laquelle il faut
s'adapter
j'essaie de sortir le plus possible sur
tout le week-end de me déplacer en
voiture et pas en transport en commun et
je porte toujours un masque je
désinfecte mes mains et j'évite les
foules
le coc vide restera avec nous pour
toujours
je pense que les vaccins vont devenir
habituelles et qu'ils devront être
réajusté chaque année en raison de
l'apparition de nouveaux variants nous
devrons donc nous habituer à cette
nouvelle réalité
ce week end des restrictions aux
frontières ont aussi été mises en place
pour les voyageurs venant de république
tchèque et de slovaquie qui devront près
monter un test négatif au risque d'être
placée en quarantaine à leur arrivée en
pologne le nombreux quotidiens de
nouveaux cas s'établit actuellement à
plus de 12000 pour une population de
moins de 38 millions d'habitants
plus de 48 mille personnes ayant perdu
la vie depuis le début de l'épidémie